what is metadata well literally it is
data about data so let's look at some
examples
we often have associated with a CD track
you know there's online databases that
associate with it who's the artist and
how long the track is where it was
recorded I would all be metadata part of
standards around JPEG and commonly use
the compression mechanism there is a
exchangeable image file format feels
except it's called which tags the image
with various pieces of useful
information the digital cameras will put
in all of the information you know so
the exposure time the camera settings
when the flash we use the whole bunch of
things that put in there very rich you
know amount of metadata can also put in
things like location so if you wander a
high you take a picture in your
smartphone you upload it to some service
and they do locate it they show it on a
map that's because the GPS coordinates
are in there as well people should be
very aware of that for fear that they
want to take a picture somewhere and
they don't want to trace to their eyes
and some people I've had some rather
embarrassing consequences when that's
happened one of the other things that
professional photographers will often do
is they will put in copyright
information information about who owns
the copyright or perhaps who you could
contact to license the image they might
even create in the license that it's
available under especially if it's
settled license is called a Creative
Commons licenses which were available
that to say how people can reuse an
image so that when you find an image
with a Creative Commons license you know
whether you can you know share it on
whether you could modify it whether you
can use it for commercial or
non-commercial use and indeed if you go
in to Google Image Search and go to the
advanced search options you can actually
search by license type you can say I
want an image that's freely reusable or
modifiable if you want to create a
PowerPoint or something and you want to
be legal honest and decent with
copyright law then you should actually
be making sure you have images that have
that sort of copyright license
associated with them as a professionals
will often put in you know just
name or email address on a website and
say it's copyright me and this is how
you contact me to get a license of
course the most people contacting a
photographer to get a license it's just
it's just way too much work and so most
people have taken a very simple
expedient of saying well don't worry
about it then
in fact the reach of images that are
there in violation of copyright is
pretty extreme
I'm justifiably very many professionals
open arms but this there's a number of
things that you'd say like this the
first thing is most digital tools were
shockingly bad at maintaining the image
method theatres across editing so many
of them will just crop it out throw it
away of course many people when they see
a picture they really like and want to
use they don't actually save these
messages to a screen shot at which point
the screen shop doesn't propagate the
metadata that may be associated with the
image is caught in the scene not if
there's several images it might be hard
to figure out which netted a does it
take metadata and their data are easily
parted and it happens a lot and you'll
see people uploading images to web
websites it may have perfectly good
metadata in it but the matter the
website will strip that I it is a matter
of concern because so many people make
their businesses out of that sort of
copyright material one of the challenges
is getting the copyright often involves
picking up the phone and talking to
someone and if the person on the other
end is a lawyer and you're negotiating
access it's going to cost you hundreds
of pounds because that's how much a
lawyer charges to pick up a phone so the
human being second isms of copyright
licensing mean that it tends to be an
expensive business but that's where we
should ask the question you know could
we build a digital means of accessing
material that had the transaction cost
that you would expect with a digital
transaction which is the transaction
cost very very little and the money
you'd be paying for the image would be
going to the artist or a photographer or
whatever and not to the legal
negotiation to get there and so for
example in the UK the copyright hub and
there's a company behind that being
promoted by the intellectual property
office to actually build an online
exchange so you'll be able to go along
and and for the transaction costs of
pence and maybe Pines
and you would be able to get you know
access to imagery that you could use
whether it's your PowerPoint your
company brochure and the whole idea is
to remove friction as the way the
connected digital economy catapult puts
it they talk about removing the friction
from copyright licensing because digital
transactions in this space should be you
know the transaction itself costs
fractions of a pence and then you're
just paying the you know for the image
rights to reuse it and I think at the
point at which you know that becomes a
prevalent way of operating and the cost
structures right then actually you know
people will stretch but certainly
there's working for corporate support
they want they want to be legal and
respect copyright and we simply haven't
today given the technology tools that
enable people but we do have these
mechanisms for buying music if not
license when you buy it you are
licensing it you are licensing it for
your personal use and a religion change
the law in the UK means that you can
switch it between formats format
switching as long as it's for your own
personal use when you don't buy
something from iTunes or something
however you are engaging it's in the
terms of conditions that in their
copyright license you've got a license
to use it for your own personal use but
we did see the same thing a number of
years ago until those legal exchanges
came available where you could get music
people were frustrated and they had
these grid mp3 players and a stack of
CDs and it seemed perfectly legitimate
to them to take the bits off the CD and
put it on the mp3 player the music
industry took a long time to wake up to
that and realize that they should simply
be the channel that collects that
revenue and if you make it easy and
simple to use then maybe people would be
willing to do that what they wanted was
a convenience and give them the
convenience then many people perfectly
happy to at legally
I encrypt something with my private keys
and then your public key and then send
it to you and if we communicate like
this I know that nobody else coming
frequencies in the amplitude and the
fears within that 3.4 coverage ban in
order to get ourselves nearly up to 56
kilobits